cnn does this thing every year where now
on new year's eve
their hosts get hammered on air and i
think it's real i think they actually
are drinking it could just be a fake
sort of performance but i think they
actually are and then they babble and
they get all goofy and they're drunk on
screen and this is supposed to be really
funny and festive so
anderson cooper leads this show and andy
cohen
who is a radio host andy cohen comes on
and he went into an admittedly
satisfying drunken rant about what a
terrible mayor new york mayor bill de
blasio was
let me tell you something cheers oh
please tell us something andy
watching mayor davasio
oh don't go on a ramp
stop going around
as the mayor of new york
the only thing
that democrats and republicans can agree
on
wow
2022.
it's a new year because guess what
i have a feeling i'm gonna be standing
speaking right here next year and you
know what i'm not gonna be looking at
dancing
as the city
comes aboard
totally right so he's completely right
about bill de blasio he's been a
complete disaster
all the democrats i know in new york
almost every single one
which is most of my friends in new york
despise the guy
i think andy cohen at least may have
actually been drunk there because
anderson cooper keeps trying to reel him
in and andy cohen just says no i'm not
going to do that and he goes on this
drunken rant which was
which was enjoyable but generally
i think the cnn drunk thing is just so
stupid more on that one second first
though
i want you to think back
not only over their past failed
predictions but over the past 90 days
how often did you eat a little too much
drink a little too much
spend a little too much time in the
office how many times did you ignore
your wife children or friends just to
thumb through social media watch netflix
youtube or a game
how many hours did you waste doom
scrolling through headlines
so many men today are distracted they're
dependent on the comforts of this world
making them incapable of even knowing
that they're not free to say no to those
things
we were made for more than this okay if
you desire freedom from those
attachments if you desire true freedom
not the freedom to pursue your appetites
like an animal but the freedom to be a
better husband freedom to be a better
father freedom to be a better man for
others i would invite you to check out
exodus 90. go to exodus 90.com michael
exodus 90 is a 90-day program that gets
us back to the fundamentals of the faith
prayer self-denial and fraternity more
than 50 000 men from around the world
catholics protestants even people who
don't align with the christian faith
have done this
of these men 99 report experiencing
greater freedom you can check it out for
yourself at exodus 90 dot com slash
michael that is exodus nine zero dot com
slash michael
this has become a meme in our culture
that now if you want to if you want to
make something really fun
you know if you want to make a form of
entertainment really fun
just get the performers drunk and that's
going to make it better
right there's drunk history oh yes
instead of just talking about history
where they're going to get drunk and
talk about history or the drunk
shakespeare yeah instead of watching
good actors perform great plays well
they're going to just get drunk
and do it isn't that going to be they're
going to impair their skills and
abilities and that'll be better somehow
yes
and you know what we're going to do
we're going to have these
people go on cnn
watching cnn always an unpleasant
experience but they're going to get
drunk and that'll be better it's just so
lazy and unattractive
it just it reminds me that we're not a
serious society in any way
i'm no i am no teetotaler far from it
let me tell you folks all right i
love
a good drink okay good cigar with a good
drink i love it
all right i've loved it for a very long
time
but i don't like being drunk
this is this is where we've lost all
sense of proportion and we've lost
the idea of the virtue of moderation
drinking is fine
christ's first miracle was turning water
into wine for people who had been
partying for quite a few days
but you need to hold your liquor people
you need to that is a good thing you
think you ever read
how much winston churchill would drink
in a single day he'd wake up he'd start
his day with scotch and soda he'd move
on he'd have champagne he'd have brandy
and this he'd been drinking all day
winston churchill was almost never seen
in public drunk if ever i'm not sure
that he ever was
that's what we've lost it reminds me of
that chesterton line a lot of chesterton
in today's show where chesterton said
the the modern world is not so awful
because it's so bad it's in many ways so
awful because it's so good we've got a
lot of virtues but they're totally out
of whack and we don't have a sense of
moderation anymore we don't have a sense
of balance
anymore we don't we can't and when you
when you get these things out of wax
when you don't have a balanced society
things start to break down hey man i'm
glad you liked that clip
you know dawg
i appreciated that you watched it if you
want to get more clips i would recommend
you ring that bell subscribe get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]